[Music]
I'm Ray Parra and today I'm making my
Thai tea pie when I first brought the
pie out to Thanksgiving my family was
like really surprised that you could get
Thai tea into a pie flavour and since
then it's been one of those things that
my family just expects me to bring to
Thanksgiving every year so my
sister-in-law will bring to traditional
pies apple or pecan or strawberry and
then I'll be in charge of the two Thai
tea pies which usually goes by faster
compared to the other pies since again
it's not something that you would be
able to get at your local pie store
Thanksgiving gets crazy at my family
because it's like loud there's a lot of
us with a family hashtag my last name is
Pilar so we had at ey so it's hearty
because there's so many of us that we
had a hard time getting photos whenever
we would take like a group photo or any
kind of photo during a party so we just
made the hashtag so that you could look
it up and find the photo online but now
it's just become like a fun thing so
Mike I only came out to California in
the 1980s the family was still
relatively small and it was just my mom
my dad my like six older half siblings
and as the years grew and as we all
became adults everyone brought something
to the table so the table just got
bigger what was originally probably
close to a traditional Thanksgiving
became something that is pretty much a
giant Thanksgiving party it's like now
we can't really fit into one table but
we'll fit into one house as we all get
older everyone brings something new so
if I showed up to Thanksgiving without a
pie specifically this tightiy pie they
would put me in the kitchen and make
this pie the first year that I actually
made this pie I've made one Thai tea pie
and then I also made an Earl Grey pie my
family liked the dear old gray pie but
it just wasn't as popular compared to
the Thai tea by my family's like want
enough that they'll be like this is good
but it's not great we just get two of
the Tai Chi pies instead of a or gray
pie but the amount of people that we do
have over for Thanksgiving someone is
always bound
forget something since I'm traveling
over there I don't really end up
forgetting a pie or anything but there
have been years where we would forget
like the lumpia someone would forget the
rice someone would forget the mashed
potatoes with the big families you have
to move fast if you're gonna hope that
someone's gonna save you a a slice of a
pie or piece of the cake it sucks for
you because not everyone's gonna say
that my favorite way to serve the
tightiy pie is to give it a nice healthy
dollop of fresh whipped cream just
because it ties it all together and it
looks really pretty I love sharing with
my family but this one is all mine
[Music]